only four gods without your kid okay
this is a giant troll splattered all
over the ground you ready you ready go
go with my love this is stupid
out of my way possessed by some evil
spirit don't move don't move
oh god another glass break ah how boring
can these ow ow
how boring can these get answer is
extremely extremely excessively boring
go on to pro can't even get me oh my
face break this is da ball go how
I won oh yeah awesome ball fall Oh today
I like the way you're handling those
balls oh yeah got them all over your
face oh that's good that's good oh
that's very good
Sanna you're being a little softer I'm
enjoying myself good those trash girls
your epic rope swing oh my neck ah grab
with space I know how to play I am too
pro to do what is this noob day on happy
wheels land
I'm so amazingly professional
oh my crotch that's okay I got the
vehicle longest harp and run I love a
pun run the fun runs are the best
try this a gun
go-go-go my favorite sports team go one
more try to actually get this guy oops
somebody can't get me I'm the
gingerbread man yeah extreme fall down
escape at the box
oh he even kicked wooden hammer Oh what
should I do with this hammer
oh okay let's try it again
quicker grab the hammer don't grab your
ding-dong grab the hammer neon sward
throw not a guy least I took you with me
okay don't kill yourself I thought I had
gotten out of the killing myself mode
but apparently I'm not okay do not kill
yourself
Jesus how hard is that don't freaking
kill yourself there we go i won
yay good for me we table out no god dude
the balls are too small ah gotta make it
I gotta make it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
fun uh wait a minute what is this level
say do this lightly hard pogo jump I can
get in the hole there we go no no Jen go
[ __ ] yeah pirate ships ah what that
man this is my ship what oh my god this
is horrific but amazing in so many ways
excuse me while I just squat down here
on the poop deck
notebook oh then always one other sap
for the romantic stories let's go meet
our lady been waiting this is like ever
absolutely seen the notebook I know that
it Ryan Gosling is such a dreamy beanie
we're gonna see our love good my love's
been hurry up your I finally just need
your head guide me rude off yeah it is
why does your nose over 105 epic ball
throw oh nothing hahaha no don't kill
self self kill dumb don't kill self van
ah I did not help me at all hey don't
kill self that's not now kill me don't
kill self [ __ ] no you were gonna go uh
oh you keep wanting to go into this
death but dump dammit
two balls just how I like it
no possible wide bleeds fire you cannot
kill me you took my arse off but my new
while young boys haha government my head
Bob that barely hurt me
we can fly over you we're so amazing why
can't and headless kid or head of kid
you must wear for the sake of your baby
[Applause]
to cut for you all bad luck aah spitting
glass break okay let's get on with it
all right
good boy it's okay you better cut your
banners so bad or you're not good enough
dad
[Music]
Oh another ball throw another day
another dollar mm one more ball we worth
it but my other but there it is ha ha
ninety three point seven nine percent
impossible this has much better odds
than the other Impossibles I played Oh
Pogo it's room I neck okay Hawks math I
failed once more
[Music]
when do I get to murder people
hi get up there get up there god damn it
you kidding me if frickin I Eve Frick
frakking kidding me all you son of a
[ __ ] I'm going this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you liked what you saw and you want to
see more why not subscribe to my channel
want to help the channel grow
leave a like added to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see
in the next video
[Music]